Chacun a sa passion, les films, la danse, le chant, le sport. Bon bah moi vous avez compris ma passion..
..c'est le football !
C'est pas vrai c'est le dessin.
Plus jeune j'ai touché à tout ce qui touchait de près ou de loin au dessin,
de la BD, de l'acrylique, du crayon de couleur, des post-its, des pochoirs
sur des photos, sur des casquettes, des papertoys, des arts toys,
des Stickers, des découpages..
Bref dès qu'il y avait un endroit vide il fallait que je le comble avec des dessins
Y'a des passions que tu peux partager,
Hein euh la danse à plusieurs, c'est bien
Le le football ! À plusieurs, c'est mieux !
Le dessin à plusieurs, c'est pas..
Oh hier soir j'ouvre la fenêtre,
et il y a un pigeon qui rentre juste..
- Je suis en train de faire mon ENCRAGE, tu me DÉCONCENTRE !
- Bouaaaaaaaouh !
Vous êtes pas capable de travailler individuellement, MAIS en groupe MERDE !
- En tout cas ça m'fait plaisir de vous inviter les mecs hein !
- STEU
- PUTAIN!
Bon bah je m'en rends compte, j'adore dessiner mais je le sais, ce n'est pas une passion qui est très... Wouah quoi !
T'es comme ça, face à ta feuille..
C'est pas une passion qui va t'aider à pécho par exemple! Y'a des passions qui marchent beaucoup mieux pour ça..
T'as un super coup de... de crayon hein !
- (Cyprien d'une voix grâve et sensuelle)
Merci ;)
Écoute, ça t'ennuie si je couche avec le mec là-bas plutôt !?
- Non non ! Pas de soucis
Je passe à l’encrage moi !
Où est ma gomme ?
- Regarde moi bien dans les yeux !
- J'crois j'ai perdu mon bleu !
Le dessin, c'est une passion qui peut arriver super tôt, hein tous les gamins ont pris
des Crayolas pour gribouiller sur des feuilles !
Bah du coup face à des passions du genre le bricolage ou le saut en parachute qui font vraiment très adulte,
le dessin ça fait assez euhh.. Enfantin !
Moi la politique, je peux en parler pendant des heures !
- On peut plus l'arrêter !
- Ah oui la politique c'est ma passion !
Et toi Cyprien quel est ta passion ?
- Ah euh le..
Le dessin
- Le, le dessin tu as dis ?
- Oui, le dessin mais j'aime aussi la politique !
- Tu ne réponds pas aux adultes, c'est clair ?
- Mais c'est vrai ! J'aime bien la politique !
- Cyprien tu FILES DANS TA CHAMBRE !
- Calme toi, calme toi
- De suite !
- Monte dans ta chambre
Comme je dessine tout le temps , j'ai pris l'option "arts plastiques" au lycée et j'ai croisé de tous les genres dans ma classe hein !
Ceux qui dessinent des bonhommes (voilà , j'en fais partit)
Ceux qui sont un peu plus poussés, qui vont t'faire des petites peintures à l'huile tout ça
Et ceux qu'on a totalement perdu !
Ouais sympa tes dessins mais moi j'vais trouver une grosse planche de bois dans la forêt,
j'vais coller des bouts de verre et du métal et des yeux découpés dans les magazines dessus
pour faire une oeuvre comme ça qui
dénonce l'impact de l'homme sur l'écologie
Mais ça tu peut pas comprendre euuuuh
C'est un truc de
Ouais toi c'est des bonhomme quoi !
Tous les ans, dans ma classe j'ai eu un mec, qui a fait une peinture avec son propre sang !
C'est pour mettre de la souffraaaance dans mon œeeuvre, pour mettre une part de moi-même,
mon ADN, c'est pour chercher la vérité dans le mensonge..
GNNNHAAAAH
Ils se sont coupés pour finalement
faire une peinture marron,
parce que oui, hein le sang sur du papier ça devient marron,
les couleurs sont fades, parce que c'est extrêmement liquide,
ça pue, et c'est extrêmement dangereux !
Top idée !
Archibald nous a quitté tragiquement,
après avoir contracté le tétanos,
suite à une coupure non maîtrisée.
Il a eu 11/20 !
J'ai eu son prof au téléphone, les couleurs sont
fades et ça pue dans la classe.
Repose en paix Archibald !
C'est important d'avoir l'avis des autres sur ses dessins, des compliments comme des critiques ..positives ou négatives,
et puis parfois, t'as des phrases tu sais pas trop.. Comment les prendre..
Franchement,
Bah euuh merc.. MerOui, oui, oui !
Tu sais dessiner toi ?
- Je.. Sais pas! Toi ?
- Mmmh chai pas non plus..
Viens on fait un bonhomme !
- On fait un bonhomme !
- Ouais
Eeeet Arrh..
- Nan ! Moi j'viens juste de..
(les 2)
OH LA CHANCE !
- Oh le gars il est..
- Oh je.. Oh C'EST TROP COOL !
OH J'AI EU TROP D'LA CHANCE !
- Mais ça t'est venu comme ça !
- Oh C'EST OUF !
(les 2)
OOOOH LA CHAAAANCE!!
JE SUIS TELLEMENT CHANCEUX ! Aucun travail que de la chance !
- Oh my hoh
C'est le mec le plus chanceux sur Terre, il s'agit... il s'agit clairement de chaaaance!
Bon j'avoue, nous, les dessinateurs ont à un petit tic énervant
Quand les gens cherchent un jeu de société, on propose toujours un Pictonnary
Voilà, je, je l'avoue ! Je le confesse, je suis désolé !
*Bruits de gorges*
Un leggings ?
- Un iPhone 1 ?
Oh.. Mais oh c'est finiii ! Ah noon !
- C'est dommage !
- Dommage !
- Mince
- Ah mince !
- C'est avoir un chat dans la gorge..
- Un chat dans la ?
- Ah ouaiih mais c'est pas clair !
Mouais parce que
- Déjà y'a pas de chat, y'a pas d'animal !
- Oui il aurait fallut dessiner un chat quoi ducoup !
- Monter sur ses grands chevaux ?
- Ouais allez !
- Allez !
- Ouais vous savez quoi, on va faire un Monopoly comme vous avez dit..
- AH BAH NAN !
- Nan t'as dit Pictonnary, on fait Pictonnary
- On s'amuse bien là !
La tecktonik ?
- Keen'V ?
- Euhh l'émail dentaire ?
- C'est une chaise..
(les 2)
Pfffff! Ah non ! Ah bah non ! Non non non non non ! Tu peux pas dire c'est une chaise !
Dissoudre l'assemblée nationale ?
- Oui
- Bien sûr ..
N'empêche tout le monde a déjà dessiné au moins une fois dans sa vie
au moins quand t'es gamin avec des crayons de couleurs, fallait pas déborder
J'dirais même que ceux de ma génération
on a tous dessiné au moins deux fois
dans sa vie, une fois quand t'es gamin
et une fois quand t'as eu ton premier ordinateur !
Regarde mon fils ! Je t'ai acheté un ordinateur personnel
- Oh regarde y'a Paint !
- C'est donc ça le dessin numérique..
Et bah c'est vraiment de la merde !
- Mais attend.. Le dessin c'est une passion qui est
Je le ramène au magasin!
J'm’en fous!
- Ah nan non non !
- Si !
- Nonn NON
Le dessin, c'est une passion qui est assez dur pour en faire son métier
voilà il faut beaucoup euh, de travail,
beaucoup de persévérance pour
réussir à vivre de la BD, du graphisme...
Et puis y'a des métiers où y'a du dessin..
Mais par contre euuh .. On oublie la passion !
Il avait aussi un visage un peu carré, il portait un bonnet !
Et euhh.. Et il avait des cheveux courts.. Blonds !
- Ok c'est bon j'ai terminé son portrait robot..
J'adore le manga !
Voilà ça m'a fait plaisir de vous parler
de ma passion
D'ailleurs, si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le dessin
J'ai fais une petite vidéo bonus en lien à la fin de la vidéo ou dans
⬇️ La description ⬇️
Où je vous donne des petites astuces pour dessiner, c'est cadeau !
Et on a pas oublié l'objectif 10 millions d'abonnés !
On y arrive très très bientôt aux 10 millions d'abonnés !
(Bon en vrai vous avez déjà dépassés les 10 millions d'abonnés
Merci beaucoup, c'est arrivé beaucoup trop vite !)
Et je vous prépare une vidéo SPÉCIALE pour ça !
Alors je vous dit à très vite sur Internet !
Je suis fichu !